[Music]
[Applause]
years terraces will be for so many years
thank you for letting us have this
moment
JLo gushes over helping her backup
dancers Tara and Lake get engaged during
her Las Vegas all I have show it was
really sweet it was really sweet he
called me and asked me if he could do it
and you know I loved all the people that
I work with all the dancers that I work
with so it was a great moment the
actress also teased the intense second
season of her NBC hit shades of blue I
mean I'll tell you this you stay with it
to the end where I wind up is nuts you
would never imagine but uh it was a
great season we uh we were so excited
it's just just more of the hurricane
that always last last days and you know
more of the slippery slope you know
trying to survive there's different
kinds of danger now it's like they have
two or three different enemies that
they're fighting off at all times the
crew her and wise and the rest of the
crew and then there's the relationship
with her and Wozniak and how it was
damaged in the first season
needs repair and what's gonna happen
there we never really feel our students
are we